so what about
life
when we uh
choose to park
our vehicles on another planet on the
moon but let's go to mars first of all
is that excite you
humans going to mars like stepping foot
on mars and when do you think it'll
happen it does excite me i think
visionaries like elon are working to
make that happen in terms of building
the road to space
we are really excited about building out
the human lived experience of space once
you get there so how are you going to
grow your food what is your habitat
going to look like
i think it's profoundly exciting but i
do think that there's a little bit of a
misunderstanding of mars anywhere in the
near future
being anything like a replacement for
earth so it is good for humanity to have
these other pockets of our civilization
that can expand out beyond earth but uh
mars is not
in its current state a good home for
humanity
too many perchlorates in the soil you
can't use that soil to grow crops
atmosphere is too thin certainly can't
breathe it but it's also just really
thin compared to our atmosphere
a lot of different challenges that would
have to be fundamentally changed on that
planet to make it a good home for a
large human civilization
how does a large
civilization of humans get built on mars
and
what do you think
where do you think it gets starts being
difficult so can you have a small base
of like 10 people essentially
kind of like the international space
station kind of
situation and then can you get it to 100
to 1 000 to a million are there some
interesting challenges there that worry
you saying that mars is just not a good
backup at this time yeah for earth i
think small outposts absolutely like
mcmurdo right so we have these models of
really extreme environments on earth in
antarctica for example where humans have
been able to go and make a
sustainable settlement
mcmurdo style life on mars
probably feasible in the 2030s so we
want to send the first human missions to
mars and maybe as early as the end of
this decade more likely early 2030s
moving anywhere beyond that in terms of
a place where like an entire human life
would be lived where it's not just you
go for a three-month deployment and you
come back that is actually the big
challenge line is just saying is there
enough um technological sophistication
that can be brought
that far out into space if you imagine
your electronics break there's no radio
shack this dates me a little bit that my
mind jumps to radio shack but there's no
you know there's no supply chains on
mars that can supply the level of
technological sophistication for all the
products that we rely on on day-to-day
life
so you'd be going back to actually a
very simple existence more like pioneer
life out west in the story of the u.s
for example and i think that the future
of larger scale gatherings of humans in
orbit or sorry in space is actually
going to be in microgravity floating
space cities not so much trying to
establish settlements on the surface
so you think sort of a significant
engineering investment in terms of our
efforts and money should be on
large um spaceships that perhaps are
doing this kind of um self-assembly all
these kinds of things and doing an orbit
maybe building a giant donut around the
planet over time
yeah that is the goal and i think the
current political climate is such that
you can't get the trillion dollar
investment to build to start from
scratch and build the sci-fi
megastructure but if you can build it in
fits and starts in little different
pieces which is another advantage of
self-assembly it's much more like how
nature works so it's biomimicry inspired
way for humanity to scale out in space
and whether it's out in space or on mars
the idea that sort of two people fall in
love
they have sex
uh a child is born
and then that couple has to teach that
child
that like we
that they came from earth i i just love
the idea that somebody's born on mars or
out in space and you have to be like
that this is not actually like the
original home right just them looking at
our at earth and being like this is
where it came from i don't know that's
really inspiring to me and the child
being really confused then wanting to go
back to tick tock or whatever
they do whatever they do in that area
i mean there's great sci-fi right about
um people being born on mars and because
it's a lower gravity environment they're
taller they're more gangly if they were
actually able to develop there and then
they come back to earth and they're like
second-class citizens because they can't
function here in the same way because
the gravity's too strong for them
you see this in series like the expanse
with the belters and these you know
different societies that uh if we were
to succeed in having human societies
grow up in different pockets it's
not necessarily going to be easy for
them to always come back to earth as
their home
you